how you doing people i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report and we've got a
first
time guest felicia michaels and
returning
reuben report uh professional max
lugavir
and let's get right to it you know i was
on twitter this morning and i do my
little morning scroll before i get out
of bed and i did not see
one uh beheading video i was absolutely
shocked nothing new in the beheading
world
uh but yeah a lot of bad isis stuff is
happening
and a egyptian social media activist her
name is aaliyah
magda almady she's 23 years old
she posted a rather interesting image on
facebook
let's take a look at the image
okay so that is her facing us and uh she
has is
obviously written on her chest she is
menstruating
on the isis flag there and then that is
another girl and she's got the other is
so isis
and she's pooping on the isis flag
uh she is getting a lot of no pun
intended
uh on facebook for this a lot of people
are very upset with her
this is a major bold statement by by a
true activist she doesn't want
these people uh taking over her country
her part of the world
uh i commend her for it um but she's
really putting herself
out there absolutely um so i guess i
don't want to be too glib about this but
i will just start with this like how
long is this girl going to live because
in this part of the world you do
something against the power
i don't know how many you know we've
done beheading videos for the last month
like how long before they get her right
my
question is uh was it spontaneous are
you just hanging out you're on your
period your friend really needs to use
the restroom you happen to have
a flag there you know what i mean that
is all right we're going
to start i like it that's good no i mean
i think it's
you know i i applaud her because that's
how you know i feel like
the ideology of isis really should be
treated like
the you know the crap that it is you
know
yeah um but yeah i worry for her where's
she based again is she she's in egypt
supposedly i'm not exactly sure where
she is right now and i'm sure she's
doing some sort of hiding situation
but she is in egypt at least last we
heard wow
yeah um bravo yeah so does this work
kind of in two ways because not only is
she making a statement about isis but
she's also making a statement for women
and it's really not going that great for
women in the middle east either right so
this is pretty good
just on the woman front i think it's
pretty ballsy because she's doing it
without a mask on i mean those guys are
beheading with
a cover over their face and she's not
doing that so right away to me
it takes a tremendous amount of balls
and more balls than what they have
yeah in my opinion um when we talk about
this do you think we we strengthen
her side or do you think we strengthen
the other side because
for you know on one hand it's we bring
attention to it yeah and on the other
hand it's like well then they go ah see
the western media
is showing this girl on us
because they hate us
yeah everything that i've seen from isis
or the islamic state whatever they're
being referred to as now i mean they're
to me they're they're almost worse than
nazis they're not friends of women
they're terrible terrible people they're
not friends of women to say yeah
just put it mildly the the religious
police i saw i saw them patrolling
raqqa that's the name of the town that
they've taken over now in northern syria
right and they're just like
i mean what a what a cancer
on on humanity they are it's just you
know absurd yeah all right well you've
given me a good segment here
uh good segue here because uh now there
are videos coming out
showing the actual brainwashing that
isis is doing
to their children uh so we've got some
video
from the middle east media research
institute
and it appears to show a young boy
pledging allegiance
to isis let's take a look
foreign
okay all right that seems pretty scary
to me
how do we i mean this is pure
brainwashing like at the most
base level right i mean as a parent
you don't know what's going on before or
after that it is brainwashing
you know i think it's wrong what could
be going on after that
but you don't you don't know you know
exactly what they're saying to that
child before
and or after you know or what the
atmosphere is
look it's absolutely wrong and it's
hideous you know but
uh i i mean i don't want you to think
i'm defending it it's
it's wrong you know i think i mean i
think it's
they're a disgusting group i have a
problem with the indoctrination
of children into any religion you know i
think it's that
you know there's a relativity there that
um i think we can we can debate but
um yeah the fact that they're making
this kid
uh cop to you know being willing to kill
himself in the name of allah you know
it's just
completely abominable so the
indoctrination in at any level because
i'm sure people are going to watch this
and they're going to say well people in
the united states are indoctrinated to
believe this or that about
so but is there something a little like
a little different about that i don't
think we're totally
not indoctrinated to be uh killing
people here
now that being said yes of course we've
killed all kinds of people we still have
drone strikes in pakistan
and all kinds of horrible stuff but
something seems a little different to me
is that uh is there something a little
different than our indoctrination
absolutely absolutely look it's wrong
and they are brainwashing but what i'm
saying is
you don't know what's being said to the
kid like oh let's make a little video
like you don't know exactly how that's
coming about i have children you don't
know you can't always make a kid
go on camera and do these things or
they'll say what we're going to do is
this and we're going to put it on
you know what i mean like you and the
child doesn't understand it
you know it is brainwashing but the
child really doesn't understand when you
say to a little kid
you're going to die or get killed
they're not really understanding
that at that age you know yeah how much
of this is just pure propaganda because
part of me when we've shown these
things and the the headings and all that
stuff like i don't want to strength i
don't want to overplay
what they really are but yet i still
think it's important that we show some
of this stuff you know twitter took down
the video
when they beheaded james foley a couple
weeks ago they were suspending accounts
that posted the video
but to me it's like we gotta sort of
show this stuff so at least we know
what we're talking about but do you
think we strengthen them sort of by by
showing the stuff and and talking about
it so i sort of asked you that before
but now we see it again here
i do think we strengthen them by by
people watching
the james foley video like i had a
moment where i was like
in a up way i do want to see it
but i don't want to see it because i
don't want
my one little click to even count on any
kind of site or any kind of twitter feed
you know i don't want that to count
but on the other hand i think the woman
with the flag i mean
uh and taking in her menstruating on
that
to me that's not strengthening their
point of view at all
but the james foley video for sure for
the record i'm pretty sure the ad rate
on a beheading video is pretty low so i
wouldn't i wouldn't worry about your
click i know what our ad rates are
around here
but i'm just saying not the ad rate
that's very funny by the way but not the
ad
rate but i'm just saying i don't even
want it to count period or know that i
did that or
you know even in my own household to
give them any kind of
props you know i don't even want to go
there yeah yeah i mean i think
you bring up a great point because it
does help perpetuate the fear
um which you know they're terrorists
that's what they want they want people
to be afraid of them but
i also kind of think that we need to
know
who's out there especially when you hear
things you know like the hundreds of
of you know amer i don't know if there
are americans or just people from
elsewhere in the world that have
joined the isis army yeah well
supposedly there's a ton
of british people uh now they've
identified the guy that killed james
foley and he was a british national so
yeah there's tons
and tons of people so right now we're
doing surveillance flights over syria
uh where we're trying to figure out
where isis is on the ground and what we
can do we're also doing pinpoint strikes
against isis in iraq and now the fbi
issued a kind of interesting statement
about what's going on let's take a look
it is difficult to predict triggers that
will contribute to homegrown violent
extremists attempting acts of violence
lone wolf terrorists present law
enforcement with limited opportunities
to detect and disrupt plots which
frequently involves
simple plotting against targets of
opportunity so basically what they're
saying is we're doing all this stuff
there and there's a chance that they're
gonna hit us here so we got a theme here
of like fear-mongering kind of stuff but
do we have to worry that any of this
stuff
is gonna come here i think we absolutely
have to worry about lone wolves i would
be more concerned about people like that
than
actual groups over here colluding to do
something you know that's what i would
be more concerned about
although rick perry said isis is coming
through the mexican border that's what
he said
rick perry man that guy he's got a bit
of it
i thought he was in jail actually yeah
yeah but that's what he said
um didn't they find there was an
american that was killed last weekend
right who had joined isis so i mean i
worry that
there are people with american passports
that have
you know converted to this horrific
ideology and are now
right and then they're going to come
back i think it's a you know it's worth
looking into and
you know being mindful of yeah so white
house press secretary jay earnest chimed
in on it as well
we're concerned about the threat that is
posed by isil but it is the assessment
as stated by the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff by the intelligence
community that there
currently is not an active plot underway
to attack
the homeland by isil you know i don't
know when i hear this stuff i kind of
think like remember before 9 11
when everybody was saying well bush was
warned a zillion times and then on
another part it's like all right if they
don't know they don't know
i guess for me it's like i don't know
what to believe anymore do you do you
suffer from some of that too
well i uh i don't know what to believe
other than the fact that don't believe
anything
like you can't i think in the last five
years with the news media we were
talking earlier about how
everything is isn't vetted like it used
to be and how rumors can run amok
uh within the news organization i think
you can't believe
everything yeah so how much of this is
just that like i turn on cnn
and like they got one guy on one side
and one guy on the other and then they
don't analyze
what they say they just say it and then
you obviously know what you're getting
at a fox and you know you're getting
msnbc so there's just nobody
like there's nothing that i turn on
where i'm like oh now i got sort of like
an honest assessment
that's why i watch the reuben report
that's why you're on the reuben
but i mean that's what i'm trying to do
is some like i don't have all the
answers but we can at least discuss this
in some kind of
open-ended way to make people think or
do a little bit of research but really
like how do you go about getting your
information on this like
what you're going to trust you watch the
vice stuff obviously yeah you know what
i was watching
if you google vice they've done a
fantastic five-part documentary about
isis where they i mean like
the journalists that they have working
for them i can't even imagine like
the situations that they put themselves
in but um but yeah that's i think one of
the best things that i've seen the vice
coverage of of isis and what's going on
in syria like just
incredible you know scenes of their
indoctrination of children
um the way they police raqqa you know
like making sure that the women are
wearing like
you know canvas you know covering
everything over their eyes like it's
it's insane yeah um i feel like i'm
watching an episode of homeland or
something i just started watching that
show that's what it feels like
yeah where uh where do you stand on like
the air strikes and all this stuff like
are you cool with everyone seems to be
cool with air strikes right now that's
like the cool thing like no boots on the
ground nobody wants that but like
airstrikes
i actually am an army brat so my father
has
incredible medical issues due to being
in vietnam he's deaf he can barely see
you know uh and other amongst other
things and i
feel like no boots on the ground but
then it's hard for me to say
we should only air bomb if we're having
such a big discussion
about the palestinians and the israelis
like you know what i mean we all have an
opinion about that but now let's you
know what i mean let's not even talk
about
airstrikes in syria you know what i mean
that's interesting so is that also part
of it that we have such an
inability to have more than one
conversation at a time in america like
we just went through like a month-long
gaza thing where that's all everyone
talked about
now we've that sort of seems like a
ceasefire is going to hold as of
yesterday
so now we can move on something else
like we seem completely unable
to talk about two things at once what's
that about i think that we should that's
just the twitter generation we should
combine our conversation with the
islamic state with our conversation
about surrounding ebola by dropping
ebola
into you know into the uh the hive mind
of the um
of the is people are gonna think you're
serious about that
i i would drop playstation four because
then you just hook that thing up and
then they have something else to do or
just give them a lot of porn yeah
they had more access to porn because
they're all doing it for the virgins
right right
just to show that they're all just
incredibly sexually frustrated they have
enough access to porn
you think they have plenty of access my
kids have access to porn
those terrorists have access for me
um all right so final thought on all
this isis stuff is uh
are we just damned if we do damned if we
don't like we up with the first
iraq war
then we left the whole place went to
these yazidi that were on the
mountain 40 000 of them were gonna get
slaughtered nobody did anything so we
ended up saving them but now more are
being killed now like it's just this
endless
like if the u.s helps it's always good
sort of short term then we
everything up then we help
like it's ju is that it are we just is
that our place in the world forever
i think it's going to be that's how it's
going to be forever unless people
understand you
nothing is a temporary fix you know uh i
was
got to perform for the troops as a
comedian in iraq and even
then and this was four years ago as we
were
out in the forward operating bases doing
comedy
you would be standing next next to one
or two soldiers here and there and they
would all say this is for nothing as
soon as we leave this is done
and and that's the way it is in like
with my parents my mother was from
berlin germany my father was in the army
she was a war bright it's like we were
there for
30 40 years and that's if we're going to
do something
people need to understand that's the
commitment you have to make yeah it's
not just still have
like 40 000 troops in germany now nobody
knows why they're there i don't think
right either yeah well because i i think
and i could be completely wrong it's
like
when they airlift people out or they
need to refuel and a bunch of stuff i
think that's
that kind of stuff but i mean it's
interesting to me that
people just don't understand nothing is
a temporary fix
yeah you know it's ridiculous well i
think that's a really great point why do
you think the troops knew it four years
ago
you know like not that we should have
stayed we obviously can't just stay
everywhere
all forever but like why if troops were
talking about it
to the comedians i feel like it because
with my experience with that and i don't
mean to take so much time but
my experience with that is that
you know when they had these forward
operating bases they did have people
from the community
participating in the forward operating
bases maybe they helped cook or clean or
whatever they did
but it was usually outcasts from the
iraqi community so
so p the people that were entrenched
within
families and with within tribes that had
good standing weren't participating
and when you're an american soldier and
you're seeing the you know you mean that
the outcast
of their society being like they had the
tendency was
that was a lot of uh gay men or
or women that didn't have good standing
in the community that were
participating and helping the americans
you know that's
i mean i've never heard that before
that's fascinating it's my take on it
you know so i i could be completely
wrong but but for a young soldier a 22
year old kid from east l.a saying yeah
this is
silliness this is silliness it makes you
really think got all this money
that was spent here and all this and
if you're performing as a woman i can
say whatever i want
to arguably the strongest
physically strongest least educated men
in our country
and they're so appreciative that people
made the trip or you can say whatever
you want
and then to see a woman iraqi woman
listening and then put her thing on and
then have to
you know go 50 feet outside the wall and
she can't even look a man in the eye you
know what i mean
it's astounding so i think if young
soldiers can figure that out
the fact that you know politicians can't
uh is is really amazing to me well i
can't possibly end the segment any
better than that so there you go
burger king do you want a whopper on a
doughnut you might just be able to get
one
because that's right burger king bought
canadian
doughnut chain tim hortons for 11.4
billion dollars we've got some more info
on the deal
with an estimated 23 billion in sales
and 18 000 restaurants in 100 countries
the new
entity would be the third biggest fast
food chain by sales
berkshire hathaway chief warren buffett
will be putting up 3 billion in the deal
he's going to get back preferred stock
that will pay him a dividend and after
the deal was made official burger king's
stock price climbed up about 16
from its closing price on friday tim
hortons jumped about 30
we've got a little more info for you
and this is where i think it gets really
interesting so in the u.s companies pay
up to 35
tax rate on both domestic income and
overseas sales
canada levies its federal corporate tax
rate of 15
only on sales within its borders then
allows companies to pay
only foreign taxes on sales abroad if
you need to pause it for a second and
reread that
this is where it kind of gets good
burger king is still going to pay the
same u.s taxes on its sales here
but will only have to pay canadian taxes
on its canadian sales
mexican taxes on its mexican sales and
so on
okay so this is interesting because
everyone said this was about taxes and
the burger king
people kind of said it wasn't about
taxes but yes it's about taxes their u.s
taxes
are going to stay the same and
everything else that they do outside of
u.s borders
and canadian borders will be taxed less
um so i want to start with warren
buffett though because everyone loves
this guy
right everybody loves warren buffett and
everyone thinks he's like the god of the
markets and all that stuff
should we be a little annoyed at mr
buffett right now for doing this
yeah i mean i think that it's it's
obvious that this is a move to
you know mitigate tax costs for burger
king right i mean
obviously they're gonna deny it but
that's like being you know being shocked
that they're gonna try to like reduce
their tax costs is like being shocked
that they're not really concerned about
the health of americans like it doesn't
make any sense yeah right i thought the
whopper was a healthy
healthy product to the big mac amazing
no um
yeah so i think it's a yeah i think it's
a crappy move
but warren buffett are you pissed at him
you know what i
am a big fan of warren buffett's i'm not
gonna lie
i'm surprised i'm really surprised and i
think
it's a terrible move i mean they're
saying that uh
corporate taxes here are 35 and in
canada it's 15
but in actuality whatever they write off
the corporations i think i read today
that burger king
pays 27 taxes on the u.s revenues i
could be completely wrong
but this is what makes me angry about is
that you're trying to shirk taxes
your workers don't make enough money and
they're accepting a lot of them have are
on welfare
your trucks that are trucking all this
food to canada and to mexico even in the
united states
are on uh government roads and that
you're shirking your tax
responsibility yet using all the
services i think that's incredibly
short-sighted isn't that the most
american thing you can do
taking advantage of the system like in a
weird way you know what i mean we had
mitt romney a guy that was uh
you know worth hundreds of millions of
dollars running for president and he was
hiding money in the cayman islands and
admitted it like openly did it
and that was the best guy the
republicans could put up like our system
is so
that like it basically the worse you
screw the system the more you're
rewarded
isn't that kind of isn't that how we've
sort of built this thing at this point
yeah it sucks i think that people would
feel a lot less uncomfortable about this
if
if the company involved in this
so-called tax inversion
were benign like apparently walgreens
attempted to do something recently like
that but then yeah but then people
boycotted it and they changed their mind
right
but burger king makes people fat and
diabetic you know it's like one of those
companies
that like doesn't really add anything
positive to the to the world in fact
they take away from people's health and
so
um that's why i don't you know i don't
feel sorry for them that they're now
encircled in this controversy
that that's an interesting idea though
so maybe if they were a different
business like they're in the business
fast food we know what
it's the business of it and the business
just you know max profits obviously and
given us a lot of shitty food
if they maybe were in the business of
something with a slightly loftier
goal or something you think people would
be angrier like does that go to the
business end of it or something like
that
i think uh people need to make
themselves more aware of what companies
are actually doing that i mean in a way
it's a good thing that burger king is
doing it because it puts more of a
spotlight on the whole situation i mean
if you go on the internet you can look
up several
uh you know tens and tens of companies
that are doing this that are in
medicine or in uh tyco is a company that
does that
and you know i mean i definitely think
that uh everyone should boycott burger
king for sure
boy copper hashtag boy copper king
people do go to burger king uh then they
should pay back
they should give us taxes for eating
their food yeah that's 10
that is not going to happen so i mean at
the end of the day
isn't this really about our tax system
here i mean is our corporate tax rate
just too high like i mean if we have if
the country that borders us to the north
that's a pretty decent country canada
can beat us at this like shouldn't this
really be not about burger king
but about the way our government provide
health care like for free for its
citizens right
that's crazy um yeah i don't i mean i
don't know what the answer is i don't
know you know i've been boycotting
burger king for 20 years just because i
you know choose health but like you know
um
it goes back to what you were saying
before you know like in the spirit of
capitalism is it really that
you know shocking of a thing that a
company would want to like seek out its
best interests financially speaking but
i don't know so almost everything we do
here at the end of the day comes down to
money in politics because
you know wall street bought the
politicians that set up the regulations
that allow companies
to do this is that so is that really the
answer when it comes down to it like
this is just about getting money out of
politics is that the only way
that you can get politicians who will
lean on wall street and then once
they're leaning on wall street wall
street will force the companies
to do different practices is that it's a
big one but
i just think as long as there's a
reflection
of what people think to the companies
and the politicians
that slow change will come as walgreens
people boycotted that they change the
minds i think
i think people really need to choose for
themselves
you know like i feel like americans
sometimes are super
lazy about understanding the news we
only go to a
new source you know on nightly
television you know if i read the news i
read the huffington post which
doesn't always have actual news but i
also read the guardian uk
you know what i mean you have to make
yourself aware and i think
uh when people about things like
the burger king
tax evasion or inversion
think that they should vote with their
money and not
eat at burger king or not go to
walgreens or not
i really think uh it's people should
stop talking so much crap
about politicians and start doing more
at personal action right so basically we
just need a list you can't eat
uh chick-fil-a because of the gay
chicken thing you can't eat burger king
because of the taxes what else
uh mcdonald's pink slime we're gonna get
to that in a little bit
give me one more one more fast just make
one up so what kentucky fried chicken
what the what are they up to again
i'm sure if they're next and they're not
fully i'm sure they're doing hard
dismantling them they're doing horrible
things to chicken
okay let's move on are you concerned
that the nsa is tracking you online and
doing all kinds of shady things behind
the scenes
well now it's going to be in front of
the scenes that's right the national
science foundation
is financing a web service that is going
to monitor
quote suspicious memes on twitter so now
it's not just their the email that
they're doing on the dl it's everything
that you put out there we've got some
more info for you
the quote truthy database created by
researchers at indiana university is
designed to detect political smears
astro turfing misinformation and other
social pollution that seems like a scary
phrase to me the open source platform
could mitigate the diffusion
of false and misleading ideas detect
hate speech
and subverse subversive propaganda and
assist in the preservation of open
debate
and a little more while the vast
majority of memes arise in a perfectly
organic manner driven by the complex
mechanisms of life on the web some are
engineered by the shady machinery of
high profile congressional campaigns
truthy claims to be nonpartisan however
the project's leaders
proclaims his support for numerous
progressive advocacy groups
including obama's organizing for action
moveon.org greenpeace amnesty
international
sierra club and more so that's from the
free beacon and in indiana you we don't
quote the free beacon here
often at the young turks but i thought
this was kind of interesting because it
could go either way right now
obama's in power and if you don't like
him they could be
tracking you and then you know what a
republican comes into power and then
they could be tracking the other guy so
i think we have to talk
about this kind of stuff um with all the
nsa stuff though
is this like does this seem like nothing
to you or does this seem like this is
the stuff that you're putting out
publicly
and they're just getting you know it's
not that they're necessarily it's not
that the government
is watching your feed constantly it's
just that they're they're going to be
aggregating all this stuff and seeing is
this is everything
true i mean half the you see on the
internet is not true probably 90
of it so there's a lot going on here
take it away
um well i have a personal story i have
this friend who
ten years ago was saying sugar causes
cancer you should put tape over your
eye you know your camera on your
computer yeah and i remember
i don't see how those two are connected
theorists kind of people yeah and i
remember making fun of her like oh yeah
the
people are trying to watch me and you
know what two days ago put a little
piece on my camera
i mean the reality is they have been
watching
or they they do they've been aggregating
for years and it's it's
for people to be so surprised by it is
silly if you are on a computer
or any electronic device that can uh
you know have a beacon or whatever they
are they are capable of
watching you and everyone just needs to
deal with that it's going to happen for
me
i personally don't care because the
worst they're going to find out is i
have a severe case
of silly girl itis so that's it you know
what i mean like who is doing all the
stuff that they're so concerned the
government is watching
right but you never know where you know
you don't want the government to have
too much power to
just be watching what you're doing all
the time they just have too much power
they just do
yeah so is there a distinction here
between like us
policing ourselves because that's what
this is that's why in a weird way that
seems almost more perverse to me
like we know what the government's doing
and it's gross and we complain about it
all the time
but this is like you're gonna be like
seeing a meme that you don't like and
like flag it and then it's going to go
into the database like we're going to be
watching each other now it's it's this
is
i mean i think that we you know we live
in a world where
you know we were talking about the
islamic state before they're using
twitter to spread their propaganda right
so i think that um building smarter
algorithms to
look at data and mass and organize it in
a way that you know that it that it
makes sense i think is useful like i was
looking at the website for truthy and
it's going to be open source you know
they have apis available for
you know people to mine the data and use
it for interesting purposes you know
they've got
whole graphics visualization stuff going
on um
so i don't think i didn't it didn't
strike me as being necessarily
that evil off the bat you know like it
kind of reminded me of uh the obama
brain initiative which i think is
amazing you know um
and so yeah like i didn't you know i
didn't think it sounded that bad
every time we do one of these stories i
immediately go to the future is going to
be evil and they're coming to get us but
you
often bring it back to like not
everything that the cars aren't
automatically going to all kill us and
the robots aren't as the sex robots
they're not going to necessarily
strangle you i have that feeling
techno optimist you know i i choose to
err on the side of optimism because i
think that technology
you know true you know there are some
costs to
uh you know the fact that like i have
all of the world's knowledge
in my pocket on my iphone i forget
numbers a lot more easily
um and the like you know i've outsourced
the left brain but i think that we have
a lot more to gain from technology than
than to lose if that power is you know
put into the right hands and
and made as democratic as possible i
think having a technology like this
being open source i think is a
sort of good way to you know accomplish
that yeah we did a story on this once
before but do you think the internet
needs like a bill of rights
like something that supersedes
governments but like just like 10
rules that govern the actual internet
and the freedoms and the rights that we
have and what the governments can
and can't do now i know this is total
pie in the sky and they're never going
to go for it and all that but like
i kind of wish that people aren't
allowed to post
unless it's verified who they are in
some sense
but then on the other hand i see where
that's incorrect and where that could
lead to a bunch of problems and that
being subversive and and wanting to post
anonymously is a powerful dirty feeling
but that being said if i was on the
internet
and i was writing all these terrible
things all on the huffington post or
wherever it is
and it's anonymous i can't say those
same terrible things to
you because even if you're telling me to
shut up i would
pick up that you think i'm crazy you
know what i mean
so i do feel like in some way i wish
everyone wouldn't be able to put stuff
on the internet unless it was verified
there's no way to do it yeah
i wish it would kind of be that way
sometimes is it also slightly
different when people in free in western
countries do it versus if you were
in egypt during the revolution
you may be needed to be anonymous to be
able to get the information out there
about where they should go
versus what happens in western societies
where if you go on huffington post
it's just anonymous crazy people
screaming at each other so there is some
there's some kind of distinction there
right right it is anonymous crazy people
here in america but then you're right in
other countries right right that's true
but in other countries where
they're trying to get some message
across and they do need to be anonymous
for their own safety i mean i
i do understand that so i don't know
it's a tricky question
on that note as i say every day don't
debate with the twitter egg
that is pretty much the best thing that
you can do but this is a perfect segue
uh
because a new study released by pew and
the
internet and american life project has
revealed that basically we
are now self-censoring ourselves so this
isn't about the government this isn't
about people
uh talking about you we're actually
doing it to ourselves
uh and let's look at the study's
findings from rutgers university
they found that while 86 of americans
would be willing to have a conversation
about an issue in person
just 42 of facebook and twitter users
were willing to post about it
so this is your you'll do something
actually in person when it's not
supposedly being recorded
but then you don't really want to make
your statement when it's going to stick
around for a while
and then if people think their opinions
would be well received they're more
likely to post about the topic
but even the thought that some of their
followers and friends might disagree
led many to self-censor so i think this
is
really really fascinating because we do
all this stuff online we put all this
stuff out there we're all on facebook
and twitter and instagram and everything
else
and we're doing it to ourselves it's not
just the government
doing it to us as a comedian you uh you
put stuff
out there you're supposed to you're paid
to say what you think
do you do any of this do you partake in
the self-censorship i do
i think the difference is like i said if
i'm talking to a person and we're
talking about something that's pretty
dark and
would agitate others even if i make a
blanket statement about something you
might give me
you know a response and then i'm like oh
you might have a point
but if you put something just cold on
twitter or facebook
then you're drawing people that you
don't even know and then people
uh just lose their minds and and so
there's no give and take
and and because it's twitter because
it's facebook like a text you can't
read exactly how people are meaning
stuff some stuff you don't need to read
exactly because it's pretty foul
but but i do think that's the reason if
i put something up and then people
i'll take it down just because it's not
a real back and forth discussion and
and if i do learn something from it i'm
like i don't really like my position on
that i kind of changed my mind because
someone gave me a piece of information
that made me
change my mind then uh it's out there
now
and people you know it's not forgiven
like it's a conversation between you and
i
now it's out there and it it's on you
for the forever
forever they're watching you forever
self-censor i do you do it the
self-censoring
it's funny i have done it and the most
recent example i could give
is i so i think that uh there was a
movie that came out recently called
boyhood by richard linklater who i think
is a genius he's a genius
i didn't think the movie was that good
but it had like a 99
on rotten tomatoes and everybody that i
know was just raving about it i didn't
think it was that good
i was like debating whether or not to
tweet that i really didn't think it was
that impressive
and i opted not to tweet it because for
a number of reasons because i felt like
it was you know and uh
maybe i was missing something you know
obviously i self-censored you know i
i didn't say what i really felt but then
um
you know i thought to myself that i'm
such a fan of his anyway that why would
i want to like
say something not nice about his work
well first off thank you for
unself-censoring right now
so you didn't want to do it on twitter
you were willing to do it on youtube
that's interesting you should talk to
your therapist about that um
yeah do you think it's partly because of
all the apologies that we see
celebrities having to make that's when i
was reading this that's what i kept
thinking like
everybody now immediately says something
and apologies and we can
we can list them all you know from duck
dynasty on down
um do you think that people that regular
citizens
are eventually going to be held to the
same standards that all the public
people are and i think
i think that's part of it what's going
on here people are afraid that their
boss
is going to see something you know back
you know this is what you're talking
about about the difference between a
one-on-one conversation and a public
thing
but you should be allowed to have your
own political views
or views on social stuff without the
fear
that you know your boss is going to see
it and get fired you know get you fired
or whatever
well look if you're if you're working at
a burger king let's just say
and you're people are at the register
and you're spouting
some religious ideology you know what i
mean
that's not correct either but if you're
on social media and your boss is on your
facebook
i mean you have to expect that people
are going to be negative about that as
much as they're going to be positive
about that and it's it's there forever
and it will follow you forever
so if you are working at burger king
let's use that example for a second if
you're working at burger king
obviously you can't do it right to their
faces but if you then have a twitter
account that has your real name on it
and maybe it does let's say it doesn't
say that you work at burger king
but and you're writing some crazy
you like you're for the kkk i don't know
um should burger king be allowed to fire
you
uh even if you don't say you work for
burger king but it's but they know with
a simple google search yeah
yeah um that's good we're slightly off
topic here okay
no i think um i think that people should
be held accountable for their for their
actions online for sure
um yeah i would be curious to know
what it is about you know presenting a
differing opinion that people
are actually afraid of is it that
they're afraid of being the ugly
duckling or are they afraid of not
getting as many likes like there are a
few confounding variables in there that
i feel like should be
considered yeah is it also that we just
live in a crazy time right now as we've
been talking about with all this
like we have so much stuff between
middle east and ebola
and nsa and like just all this crazy
stuff that i do sense online now people
are just
yelling at each other constantly and i
do try my best
to follow people i don't like almost as
much as i follow people i like
and sometimes i don't succeed and i
unfollow people because i can't take it
anymore
but like i try to because i don't want
to live in that echo chamber do you try
to follow some people that you don't
agree with
i do because because putting stuff on
facebook and twitter i mean for me
the thing that i have the most fear of
getting called out
is not being knowledgeable enough about
what i'm talking about you know so
i do it's never stopped anybody else i
don't
see why but i don't want to embarrass
myself in that way
of just that i am not well read enough
about a certain subject so
but that being said i mean i i do think
that people should be held more
responsible for what they're saying
and to not to just the public but to
themselves and not just to be talking
out of their butts
you know to that point when this whole
yazidi thing happened
on the mountain a couple weeks ago um i
tweeted
that something like you know the yazidi
are trapped on a mountain
isis is about to kill them the world
doesn't care um
it got 1800 retweets it was the number
one retweeted thing about the yazidi and
then we had airstrikes the next day i
was like wow maybe
my little tweet had something to do with
this the picture that i attached to it
was was a wrong picture it was from
syria from like two years before
so i made a mistake and it's like then i
did issue a retraction
for that uh but like delete the tweet
though i didn't you can't read i mean at
that many retweets you can't
you can't so i guess that was the
message here don't delete a tweet if you
have that many
retweets okay on a final note
pink slime you know about pink slime
we've talked a lot about pink slime
it is making its way back for a series
of reasons let's look at what pink slime
looks like first
so this is this is what actual pink
slime and if you haven't seen our videos
on pink slime i
highly recommend you just google we'll
annotate to our old
pink slime video so this is what pink
slime looks like and basically
what pink slime is is just the awful
pieces
of the meat because they want the
cheapest piece the pieces that literally
like are falling off the bone that are
all
gross and disgusting and then they jam
them together they run them through
ammonia to get all the bacteria off it's
a pretty
awful situation we'll get to more about
that in a second now let's look at the
picture for that everyone thinks of pink
slime
so this is the rumored picture of what
pink slime really looks like so the
other one
is what it does look like this is the
rumored picture of what it may look like
in like an earlier
state or something like that um and now
let's uh look at a little bit of the
background story on pink slime's demise
in 2012 abc news and celebrity chef
jamie oliver exposed the low-cost meat
product pink slime
mcdonald's and taco bell renounced it
and public schools around the country
stopped serving it by may 2012
beef products inc the inventor of the
product was on the brink of collapse
closing three of its four plants and
laying off 700 people but in august bpi
reopened one of its closed plants
and a little bit more for you this is
from dan
hale who's an animal science professor
at texas a m
he said the main issue is the drought a
lot of the u.s
especially the parts that raise cattle
have experienced a severe drought and
those animals are no longer available
for producing calves that we can in turn
generate for beef
trimmings so a lot of the global warming
people are going to say there's
some issues there because you know the
cow farts are also creating methane and
then that heats up the world now
you know all about that um you're our
cow fart guy
um apparently yeah so we have there's a
series of problems here
pink slime of course is cheaper than
when you make this meat it's a lot
cheaper because you're getting those
crappy
little extra pieces instead of the good
cuts um
the science is inconclusive as far as i
can tell whether this is actually worse
for you once they eat it people say it's
not going to kill you
the idea of eating something that's been
washed pneumonia seems kind of
disgusting to me
but this is one of the stories where all
the science people start yelling at me
because it seems inconclusive can you
clean up anything
of what i just said because i know you
know a bit about it well i think that uh
first of all it sounds disgusting it is
true that your body generates
a small amount of ammonia but that's
what you excrete in your urine so it's a
waste product in the body
um and uh yeah the meat that they use is
is from parts that i think are like
closer to the surface or something and
so they're
very you know likely contaminated with
things like e coli and stuff it's a
really gross
thing but then again how do you how do
you get a burger for 80 cents without
using you know meat that's questionable
right so that's what so it's a couple
things that are happening here partly
they're having they we have less access
to the animals because of the drought
and other climate related things then on
top of that we have a bad economy so
people don't want to spend as much so
you want an 80 cents hamburger well then
that's how you're going to get it that
way
is this story just like the story to me
is like everything which is why we talk
about it all the time because it's like
about the gross food that we eat
it's about the economic disaster we're
in it's about the earth it's a it's a
little
something for everybody my question is
if you're at the grocery store
does it say it on the packaging no no
or the ammonia or all those is that said
on the passion so
they don't have to they don't have to we
did a story a couple weeks ago how even
the phrase all natural
actually means nothing it's on
everything all the time all
natural um but no they don't have to say
it so for example if you were to get
trader joe's just like ground beef from
trader joe's
um technically they could be using the
pink slime this ammonia thing
they i did a little googling they don't
do it so that i'm still okay getting my
meat there
but yeah you don't know and that's the
so is that a bigger product problem too
that we don't package things correctly
and we and our labeling and all that
that's a huge part of the problem
absolutely yeah i mean i know that
there's
uh efforts underway and i don't know
where they currently stand to get uh
gmo products labeled demanded you know
uh mandatorily is that a word close
enough yeah
so uh yeah you're gonna make them do it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um and i think
that would be definitely uh
very helpful um as far as this pink
slime stuff goes because it's gross it's
definitely not
something i want to consume yeah all
right so for the people that say though
the the lower economic end of spectrum
that those people need options
why is it that we can't make healthy
food cheaper
that's what i think all the time like it
seems to me all the process stuff
and all it goes through so many
different things to become what
it is in that frozen package like that
should be more expensive
rather than the stuff that just pops out
of the earth and you eat it and yet for
some reason
that's reverse what do we do so that
people that can't afford
this stuff can eat healthier that's such
a tough question i don't know if i have
an exact answer for that all i can say
all i can say is i do think it should be
on packaging i think it should not
in any sense be served to school
children
at all because they're going to have it
in their system for the longest you know
i think that's not correct and i don't
know what the answer is i mean i think
uh we have to be more responsible as a
society
in understanding when the ebb uh the
food chain ebbs and flows that we have
to kind of go with it you know we get
enough protein
in our diets uh you know as far as other
things that we consume and
and i don't know what the answer is as
far as poverty uh
people that are underserved how they go
about it i don't know what the answer
should be
do you think the answer partly is that
we need to show some of these like if we
could get a real expose on how this
stuff is done because it's hard to get
video of it
of the actual process which is why we
don't have video to show you guys right
now like
all right yeah i think i think education
plays a huge role in it i mean it's you
know some people
uh i was actually on the episode when uh
when mcdonald's voluntarily when they
removed the pink slime
okay so we'll annotate to that right now
yeah and i i think that it's always an
educational issue you know i think that
the more people
can understand uh how unhealthy this
stuff is for you
they would then opt for maybe the more
expensive products which would you know
demand obviously would bring the price
down but in the end you know
whether or not you're spending more at
the checkout at your supermarket i mean
it's going to alleviate health care
costs down the road i mean if you think
that like
grass-fed meat is expensive look at
cancer i mean that's like a really
expensive thing cardiovascular disease
chronic disease is like the most
expensive thing so
i think education i think that they're
that there needs to be what you know
what you were saying a big expose
i think education is the right answer uh
hearing you say that because then i
think about my children my children
learn how to do powerpoint in seventh
grade you know what why not
take that off the table and teach them
how to read labels yeah
instead of focusing on technology
technology technology
how about some base stuff you know that
they can understand even boys
who don't do a lot of men i mean they do
shop but i'm saying
generally in families it's not the man
who shops everything
but it should be overall education
towards our children of
what you're eating and what a diet
should consist of that's more than what
they're giving now because everyone
wants everyone to be on the internet
you guys have given me a perfect out to
this show education i think we're doing
a little of that here and if we
maybe brought up something that you
don't think we gave you the correct
answer to well then
uh you have a computer i'm pretty sure
you're on it right now felicia max thank
you guys their twitters are right down
below
and check them out we'll put websites
and all that good stuff and we will see
you again next week thank you guys